.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME
TONIGHT.
I APPRECIATE IT NOW, JOHNNY JOEY
JONES AS YOU KNOW HIM WELL IS A
RETIRED U.S. MARINE.
AND WE'RE VERY PROUD TO HAVE HIM
AS A FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
YOU HAVE BEEN WITH US A GREAT
DEAL.
YOUR PERSPECTIVE HAS BEEN KEY
AND FUNDAMENTAL AFTER WHAT YOU
JUST HEARD FROM THE SECRETARY OF
STATE, WHAT ARE YOUR FEELINGS
TONIGHT?
>> YEAH, FIRST, I WANT TO START
BY SAYING MY THOUGHT AND PRAYERS
AND MY LOVE AND SUPPORT AND
EVERYTHING YOU NEED IS WITH THE
FAMILIES OF THE 13 WE LOST.
I'M EASY TO FIND IF ANY OF THOSE
FAMILIES NEED ANYTHING FROM ME.
PLEASE LET ME KNOW I'M THERE TO
HELP YOU ANY WAY I CAN.
ANY ORGANIZATION THAT I SUPPORT
OR KNOW.
WE'RE HERE FOR YOU.
SECONDLY,I WOULD LIKE TO SAY TO
THE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THAT
FLED AFGHANISTAN BECAUSE YOU
HELPED US AND YOU BELIEVED IN
US, WE ARE HERE TO WELCOME YOU
AND ANYTHING I CAN DO FOR YOU,
PLEASE LET ME KNOW.
LASTLY I WILL SAY FOR OVER
FAMILY THROUGHOUT AND GOLD STAR
FAMILY WHO BLED AND SHED POUND
OF FLESH FOR THIS WAR I LOVE YOU
AND APPRECIATE YOU.
I CAN'T TELL YOU DON'T THAT YOUR
SERVICE AND SACRIFICE MEANT WHAT
YOU THOUGHT IT DID WHEN YOU WERE
THERE.
I CAN'T TELL YOU DON'T THAT IT
MEANT THAT OUR COUNTRY WOULD BE
SAFER.
I CAN'T TELL YOU DON'T THAT IT
MEANT WE WOULD SEARCH DOWN AND
KILL THE PEOPLE THAT TRIED TO
KILL US BECAUSE I JUST DON'T
KNOW IF THAT MISSION IS
ACCOMPLISHED BUT WHAT I CAN TELL
YOU IS EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US
THAT BLED AND EITHER TOOK SOME
FAINTING BREATHS OR LAST BR T
THERE'S WE DID IT BECAUSE WE
KNEW THE PEOPLE TO OUR LEFT AND
RIGHT WOULD DO IT FOR US.
IF THAT'S WHAT IT TOOK, IF IT
TOOK US DYING SO THEY WOULD GO
HOME THEN BY GOD THAT WAS WORTH
IT.
I WANT EVERYONE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT'S WHAT IT WAS WORTH IT I
DON'T KNOW IF THE MISSION LAID
OUT BY OUR LEADERS ON OUR
GOVERNMENT WAS ACCOMPLISHED OR
FULL HEARTEDLY ATTEMPTED TO BE
ACCOMPLISHED.
I DON'T KNOW THAT.
I DON'T TRUST POLITICIANS OR
TRUST THIS TYPE OF DIPLOMACY ANY
FURTHER THAN CAN I THROW IT AND
A GUY WITH NO LEGS CAN'T THROW
REAL FAR.
I WILL TELL YOU I BELIEVE IN THE
MEN AND WOMEN I SERVED WITH I
BELIEVE IN THE PURENESS OF OUR
INTENT.
AND WHEN THE SECRETARY OF STATE
STANDS UP THERE AND TELLS ME
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO KILLED MY
BROTHERS AND TOOK MY LEGS CAN
EARN OUR TRUST?
WELL, THANK GOD THIS IS
TELEVISION NEWS AND NOT JUST A
CASUAL CONVERSATION BECAUSE I
WOULD HAVE WORDS FOR HIM NOBODY
WANTS TO HEAR.
>> Tammy: I ALSO KNOW SOME
PRETTY HARSH WORDS WHICH WE WILL
BOTH KEEP TO OURSELVES.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS IS A
REMINDER THAT LEADERSHIP
MATTERS, WE KNOWS THAT A
MILITARY MAN, WE KNOW THAT IN
LIFE.
THIS IS LEADERSHIP MATTERS.
WE KNOW THIS IS NOT A REFLECTION
OF THIS COUNTRY OR OF OUR
MILITARY OR OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THAT IS WHAT IS SO SHOCKING THAT
WE ARE WILL TO MAKE SACRIFICES.
DID YOU SO.
AND EVERYONE ELSE IS WIG TO.
WHAT'S SHOCK SOMETHING NONE OF
THIS HAD TO HAPPEN.
THIS IS NOT A NATURAL END TO
WHAT THIS -- WE ALL WANTED TO BE
OUT OF THERE BUT NOT LIKE
RUNNING AWAY TO QATAR.
NOT RUNNING AWAY AND GASLIGHTING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT
OR IS NOT HAPPENING.
LET ALONE ABANDONING.
WE ABANDONED PEOPLE WITH AN
ARBITRARY DEADLINE.
IS THAT -- HOW DO WE -- HOW DO
WE PROCESS THAT?
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO PEOPLE?
>>
>> I JUST HOPE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND SOMETHING
REALLY SPECIAL ABOUT THIS
COUNTRY.
BLOOD IS THE EASIEST CURRENCY TO
ACQUIRE.
WE OFFER IT UP.
WE VOLUNTEER MILITARY.
I DON'T KNOW MANY THAT DIDN'T
BEG TO GO ON DEPLOYMENT.
CAN YOU GET BLOOD REAL EASY.
THE INTEREST ON THAT, THE
PAYMENT, THE INTEREST ON THAT
CURRENCY LAST AS THE LIFETIME
BECAUSE THOSE ARE BROKEN HEARTS
THAT RIPPLE THROUGHOUT THIS
COUNTRY.
AND SO THE NEXT TIME A
POLITICIAN STAND AT THAT BULLY
PULPIT AND PROMISES YOU
SOMETHING LIKE A WAR, ASK
QUESTIONS.
AND HAVE CONSEQUENCES AT THE
BALLOT BOX BECAUSE WE KNOW NOW
REGARDLESS OF PARTY WE CAN'T
TRUST THEM.
BEFORE THEY SEND OUR SONS AND
DAUGHTERS WE KNOWED TO KNOW WHY
AND HOW THEY ARE GOING AND HOW
THEY ARE GOING TO GET BACK.
>> Tammy: I'M A PARTISAN FOR
AMERICA AND YOU ARE AS WELL.
THIS IS ABOUT THE HUMAN
CONDITION.
AND WHAT THE GREATEST COUNTRY ON
EARTH, WHICH WE WAKE UP IN EVERY
SINGLE DAY, THANK GOD, IS
CAPABLE OF DOING.
JOEY, I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO
SOMETHING FROM GENERAL
McKENSEY WITH CENTCOM GIVING
PRAISE TO THE TALIBAN.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> THE TALIBAN HAVE BEEN VERY
IMAGINATIC THEY WERE USEFUL TO
US AS WE CLOSED DOWN OPERATIONS.
>> Tammy: ONE FAMILY AT LEAST
THROUGHOUT BEGGING JOE BIDEN TO
GET AN AMERICAN BACK WHO WAS
KIDNAPPED BY THE TALIBAN OVER A
YEAR AGO.
THEY ARE STILL HOLDING
AMERICANS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF A MAN IN
UNIFORM WHO MAKES A STATEMENT
LIKE THAT ABOUT THE ENEMY?
>> THAT'S TOUGH.
I DON'T KNOW THAT MAN.
AS FAR AS I KNOW I DIDN'T SERVE
UNDER HIS COMMAND.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT POLITICAL
PRESSURE ARE ON HIS SHOULDERS,
BUT I KNOW WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A
MARINE.
I KNOW WHAT IT MEANS TO BLEED
WITH MEN AND WOMEN.
AND TO HOLD THEIR HAND WHEN
THEY'RE TAKING THEIR LAST BREATH
AND TO DO EVERYTHING I CAN
EVERYTHING IN ME.
IF IT MEANS WALKING DOWN AND
LEAN EVERYTHING A BOMB AND
TAKING A DAMN GOOD GUESS TO KEEP
THEM ALIVE EVEN THAT MEANS I GET
BLOWN INTO PIECES THAT'S OAK.
I WOULD NEVER LOOK HIM IN THE
FACE EVEN IF THE PRESIDENT WHO
WAS THE UNITED STATES WHO WAS MY
BOSS AT THE TIME TOLD ME TO AND
SAY SOME TRASH LIKE THAT ABOUT
THE PEOPLE TRYING TO KILL HIM
YOU CAN SAY YOU ARE PROUD OF
THIS MISSION WE JUST
ACCOMPLISHED AS FAR AS AIR
LIFTING 100,000 PEOPLE OUT OF A
COUNTRY THAT'S ABOUT TO GO TO
RUIN BUT TO GO SO FAR AS TO BE A
SPIN DOCTOR FOR AN ORGANIZATION
THAT LITERALLY TORTURES PEOPLE,
OPPRESSES THEM, AND KILLS THEM
HOW DARE YOU AND HOW DARE YOU
EVER EVER LOOK TROOPS IN THE
FACE AGAIN AND ORDER THEM INTO
COMBAT.
YOU DON'T DESERVE IT YOU JUST
DON'T GET TO DO IT.
YOU DON'T GET TO PLAY BOTH SIDES
OF THE BALL WHEN YOU PUT THAT
UNIFORM ON AND YOU ASK OUR 18
AND 19-YEAR-OLDS TO GO BLEED AND
DIE FOR THIS COUNTRY.
EACH IF WE ARE SMART ENOUGH TO
KNOW WHAT THE COST DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING TO YOU I DON'T MEAN
GENERAL BUT POLITICIANS EVEN IF
WE ARE SMART ENOUGH TO
UNDERSTAND THE POLITICS BEHIND
IT WE RAISE OUR RIGHT HANDS AND
BEHIND IT WE DO IT WITH HONOR
AND DO IT BECAUSE WE LOVE THIS
COUNTRY.
EVEN IF IT'S SOME PARTISAN WAR,
IF IT CAN KEEP OUR ENEMY AT BAY
ONE MORE DAY THAT'S WORTH IT HOW
DARE YOU THINK THAT YOU CAN LEAD
TROOPS AND STAND UP THERE AND
SPEAK GLOWINGLY ABOUT THE PEOPLE
HAVE TRIED TO KILL US FOR 20
YEARS.
JUST HOW DARE YOU DO THAT?
>> Tammy: IT IS SHOCKING.
>> IF YOU WANT TO WITHDRAW AND
BOTCH IT, TURN IT INTO AN
EVACUATION, AND SPIN ON THAT,
THAT'S OKAY.
LISTEN, I AM PROUD OF THE MEN
AND WOMEN THAT GOT EVERYONE OUT
OF THERE.
BUT TO GO SO FAR AS TO BRAG ON
THE TALIBAN, IT'S BETRAYAL IS
WHAT IT IS.
>> Tammy: IT IS.
AND IF THERE IS A POINT WHERE
YOU HAVE TO DO THAT OR YOU COULD
RESIGN IN PROTEST WHERE THERE IS
THIS UNDERSTANDING ABOUT WHAT IS
APPROPRIATE, WHAT DECENCY REALLY
IS IT'S HARD ENOUGH WITH
EVERYONE WHO SERVED, YOU AND
YOUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS, NOW
WATCHING THIS COLLAPSE, BUT THEN
TO PRAISE THE PEOPLE AS THEY
STOOD THERE AND RAIDED AL-QAEDA
AND AIDED BIN LADEN AS WE ARE
JUST WITHIN A COUPLE OF WEEKS OF
THE AN VERSE SATISFY
SEPTEMBER 11TH, IT IS
REMARKABLE.
IT IS ALSO, SIR, I THINK YOU
WOULD AGREE WITH ME
UNACCEPTABLE.
GOD BLESS YOU, JOEY, IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE EVEN REMOTELY
ASSOCIATED WITH YOU.
KEEP UP THE GREAT WORK.
I KNOW, OF COURSE, PRAYERS FOR
YOU AND FOR EVERYONE.
IT IS DIFFICULT BUT WE ARE
STRONG PEOPLE.
WE KNOW THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
CHANGES AND YOU ARE IN THE
FOREFRONT OF REMINDING US WHY.
THANK YOU, SIR.
>> THANK YOU AND DON'T FORGET
ABOUT THOSE STILL RECOVERING
FROM THAT BOMB THAT WEREN'T
KILLED BY IT.
WE NEED TO PRAY FOR THEM.
>> Tammy: YES.
WE HAVE A FEW OF OUR TROOPS I
KNOW HAVE WHERE ARE ALREADY BEEN
TRANSFERRED HERE TO THE UNITED
STATES.
FAMILIES ARE ASKING FOR PRAYERS
FOR THE SERIOUSLY INJURED AND